continúen las labores de exhumación
entre los cuerpos desenterrados las
autoridades locales hablan de algunos
ancianos Y al menos 17 militares se
están realizando exámenes en los cuerpos
se han encontrado nuevas pruebas de
tortura utilizada contra las personas
enterradas allí en áreas de la región de
harkif se han encontrado más de 10
cámaras de tortura en varias ciudades y
pueblos según el fiscal de la región uno
de los cuerpos encontrados tenía una
cuerda alrededor del cuello y las manos
atadas
se están realizando otros trabajos para
exhumar los cuerpos de las personas
enterradas aquí todavía no hemos podido
identificar a esas personas esos cuerpos
serán exhumados y enviados al amor de
dejar Kids para realizar controles
médicos y tomar muestras de ADN para una
mayor identificación de estas personas y
las causas de su muerte
el jefe de la administración regional
pero rusa que huyó de la zona ante el
avance de kiev acusó a las fuerzas
ucranianas de orquestar las a
descubiertas en el zoom el Ministerio de
defensa ruso también negó las
acusaciones ucranianas al tiempo que
acusó Ucrania de Buscar provocar un
desastre en la central nuclear de esa
policia el régimen de kiev ha renunciado
sus provocaciones destinadas a crear un
posible desastre tecnológico en la
planta de energía nuclear de sarilla
selenski por su parte afirmó el viernes
que se contabilizarían unas 450 personas
enterradas en la fosa común de
confirmarse esta cifra sería la más
grande que se haya encontrado en Europa
desde la guerra de los balcanes
observadores de derechos humanos de la
ONU serán presentes en el sitio para
establecer lo que pudo haber sucedido